en france 24 es momento de hablar de
economía por ello en el estudio me
acompaña mi compañero jorge hurtado
jorge bienvenido empezamos en eeuu con
la firma del presidente yo vaivén a la
ley de infraestructuras cómo se
invertirá ese dinero bueno valentina ese
dinero irá a carreteras puentes sistemas
de agua banda ancha puertos vehículos
eléctricos y hasta energía luego del
festejo en la casa blanca donde
estuvieron presentes gobernadores y
alcaldes de ambos partidos así como
líderes sindicales empresariales
varios analistas señalaron que un billón
de dólares no alcanzaba para compensar
década de abandono del gobierno para
mantener y actualizar la infraestructura
de ese país al menos en carretera se
estima que es la mayor apuesta desde la
creación del sistema interestatal de
autopistas esa es una de las partidas
más grandes que asciende a 110 mil
millones de dólares según la casa blanca
una de cada cinco millas en autopistas y
carreteras están en mal estado tan sólo
la reestructuración de puentes costará
40 mil millones de dólares la nueva
partida contempla la modernización del
servicio ferroviario y la construcción
de una red nación de carga de vehículos
eléctricos esto declaró el presidente
your building previo a su firma hoy
con esta ley nos centramos en hacer las
cosas bien representa la presidencia
porque la única manera de hacer avanzar
a este país en mi opinión era mediante
el compromiso y el consenso así es cómo
funciona este sistema así es la
democracia estadounidense y voy a firmar
una ley que es realmente importante
porque hemos hecho que nuestra
democracia funcione para el pueblo
estadounidense
por otro lado el plan de infraestructura
pretende construir líneas nuevas para la
transmisión de energía renovable y que
sean resistentes al cambio climático esa
inversión es de 65 mil millones de
dólares otros 55 mil millones son para
mejorar el acceso al agua potable según
el gobierno 10 millones de personas
enfrentan problemas de acceso al agua
potable en ese país una de las
inversiones más esperadas para los
puertos y aeropuertos en un momento en
que el mundo enfrenta bloqueos en la
cadena de suministro ahí se contemplan
17 mil millones de dólares en
infraestructura portuaria así como 25
mil millones para mejorar la
infraestructura de los aeropuertos y
pistas terminales pero la economía de
eeuu vive tensos momentos con la
inflación interanual
62 su máximo desde 1990 afectados sobre
todo por el aumento de los precios del
combustible los alimentos y los
automóviles el presidente demócrata y su
partido quieren demostrar que pueden
avanzar en su agenda antes de las
elecciones de medio término de noviembre
de 2022 cuando los republicanos van a
buscar recuperar el control de ambas
cámaras del congreso bueno ahora nos
vamos a argentina porque luego de las
elecciones cuál es el panorama económico
en esta nación
bueno vall entiende tras la derrota del
oficialismo la firma goldman sachs
anticipó un escenario de mayor
volatilidad a nivel político y económico
el resultado de las elecciones supone
que el gobierno de fernández tendrá que
negociar con la nueva oposición lo que
podría generar un torbellino político y
económico conversamos con juan carlos
juárez ex diputado y analista político
sobre el panorama tras esta elección y
esto fue lo que nos dijo
un bosque al diálogo de manera urgente
al sector empresarial a los sectores
sociales y a la oposición con un
programa claro contundente y que cada
uno de estos actores siente que debe ser
convocado pero para un programa que
realmente sea posible y que sea
participativo con cada uno de los
actores que son llamados al diálogo de
todas darse esta circunstancia en los
próximos años le va a resultar
muy dificultoso al gobierno poder
sostener equilibrio en lo económico y en
lo social jorge vamos con los
indicadores económicos de la jornada
bueno empezamos con wall street que
cerró negativo por el aumento de los
rendimientos del tesoro que mermó el
apetito por las acciones tecnológicas en
europa los comentarios de la jefa del
banco central europeo- christine lagard
contribuyeron a rechazar las apuestas de
una política monetaria más estricta
mientras que la caída de las mineras
mantuvo las ganancias y en latinoamérica
el mercado bursátil en argentina se
contrajo luego de la derrota del
oficialismo en las elecciones de ayer y
cerramos con la cifra del día bueno la
cifra del día en nueve mil 940 millones
de dólares ese es el gasto público
presupuestado para la república
democrática del congo del golpe de la
pandemia de las finanzas públicas del
congo del congo mejoraron este año
debido a la elevada producción de los
principales productos de importación el
cobre y el cobalto jorge muchas gracias
por esta ampliación y a ustedes por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que hay
más en france 24
[Música]